[Music]
me
[Music]
up
[Music]
is
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by production.com
you don't have to be a freeloader your
whole life the good news is that you can
support this show and the fight by
buying some really cool clothes.com
[Music]
[Music]
food
[Music]
strangers
[Music]
[Music]
can we show the steam on this is it
really hello thank you johnny boy thank
you can we get the steve let me see hold
on a second now you guys are ready for
the sip let me see does this
can we get the steam on this thing i'm
trying to think what do we need contrast
here it's like a witch's brew blow on it
what'd you put in here you put i told
you no more eye of newt well dang it
keep in mind look this is one of those
things when you take a sip and you're
planning on it being cold it's a very
different approach correct if you take a
sip of something hot yeah yeah so
everything's going to taste like rubber
for the rest of my life
thank you very much
glad to be with you we have
we have a lot to get you to talk about
today everyone's talking about potito
yeah but yeah
am i saying that correctly i don't know
quickly potato gavin
but the main issue is um
uh that joanne reed's an idiot well
that's true i mean yeah yeah yeah enjoy
read joy and read i don't know if
anthony i don't know or not i really
don't care my mouth is burnt
it's hard to think i'm going to sound
like like squints and christmas story
here in a minute
are you having a stroke so no it's
because of the drink oh gosh he just
can't follow along no hey he always
thinks it's a stroke
everything's a stroke because it's a
deeply rooted fear so we're going to be
talking about that we're going to be
talking about uh uh
really more so a lot of people ask me
what can you do look people feel
helpless the media has sort of globbed
onto this this story and obviously your
heart goes out to a woman who is
negatively effective
negatively affected her family of course
that being said this kind of thing
happens all the time and the media wants
you to feel as though you are beholden
dependent on the federal government to
save you there are things you can do to
protect yourself not saying that this
person didn't follow these instructions
right i just hopefully give you some
some tools here today as opposed to a
john oliver trevor noah who just [ __ ]
about stuff and never offer a solution
hey here's a hint
start carrying always carrying always
because the cops if the police response
time is two minutes well guess what yeah
that's two minutes too late yep uh dave
linda you're here i'll go to stroke man
afterwards you have a show coming up uh
boy
is it mon hall pennsylvania october
october 1st as well as this weekend the
funny bone in
albany new york i believe or alban
albany new york
there's no vaccine mandate to see those
shows there's no vaccine mandate and the
one is a theater show in munhall
pennsylvania which is one of my first
big theater oh yeah awesome a lot of fun
yeah also clothes optional he said also
i imagine that's the only thing to do in
munhall pennsylvania i prefer everyone
come as donald duck no pants
a nice hat shirts everywhere nice little
hi gerald a how are you i am well it's
not a stroke it's not a stroke
and quarter black yeah what's going on
yeah yeah i'm excited when are you going
to cut the hair never yeah are you
serious it also it also reduces your
hood pass when it's as straight as can
possible
it does too yeah if you look like david
man what are you talking about yeah yeah
you're going you're like hey no man i'm
uh i'm uh biracial why do you look like
the drummer from weezer
you know how long he spends in the
morning straightening that yes i told
you
man that was a fro at 5 30.
so before we move on to we also have a
clip of norm being right we're going to
continue honoring norm a lot of people
have moved on it's it's still messed me
up all week i've never been that sad
about someone dying who i don't know but
first this is uh i guess we're going to
play a game a little bit of a game
i'm going to show you a clip and you got
to figure out what happens next okay
let's go here we go
what happens next wait what okay is that
a hole in the mirror walks up to a hole
in the ground looks inside i'm hoping
it's a cobra and it bites some of the
nuts hey a snake pops out hey whoa
that's actually an option
a snake pops out of the hole and bites
him in the crotch and he says oh not
again okay b
the hole explodes blowing the man's
shoes off see the man goes too close to
the hole
and collapses inside
i have no idea the floor collapses and
he falls i have no idea i don't want to
spend too much time i'm going to say a i
want this guy to fall through and just
disappear trap door i want them to make
love to that hole like it's their
wedding night yes
and then there will also be a cobra oh
right
all right let's see what happens all
right here we go what happens
oh oh no i don't think we're allowed to
show oh he's okay no he's okay okay he
blew his shoes off what is this juice
came right off what is this a cartoon
yeah how is that man not dead that is an
acme bomb if i've ever seen one wow
did he run away and paint a tunnel on a
wall and run through it after this could
be difficult without shoes that was a
jerky boy sketch
my shoes fell off there was a bomb and
they fell off there wasn't even any
blood
oh he was he literally just took his
shoes off
it was a very ineffective bomb this is a
shoe removal bomb yeah
seems a bit overkill but just go with it
it's very specific with james but well
look they're going to turn james bond
into a woman she's like anyone hurt them
just want to scare them could we like a
bomb that really mess ruins their shoes
messes the shoes up
maybe a bomb that i put in their new
handbag
pick a restaurant
a bomb that lets you pick off the menu
standard
just
okay stop flipping the menu yeah the
nice restaurant there's one
it's side you never take me we'll get
restaurants we'll get to james bond in a
second but uh my question to you look
and we're going to talk about quite a
bit today why do you think that the
media immediately starts race-baiting on
something like i this this situation
with with uh i want to make sure gabby
petito yeah yeah i don't know why race
interest in the equation i don't know
why race enters into the equation with
james bond that's the theme we'll be
talking about today and i think that
it's making everyone pretty damn tired
of well the race injection into every
conversation it absolutely is turning
people into racists yeah especially in
places where it just doesn't make any
sense not necessary and you'll see
what's going on but before we get into
this
uh you know a lot of people talk about
nor mcdonald's they show the moth joke
they show he was very funny obviously
but nor macdonald was very well read
very open about his faith and he was
he would say that he wasn't political
but if you actually look at his
interviews he was intensely
informed on politics and here's another
instance of nor macdonald being right
that the celebrities who jump on the
bandwagon don't want to show you he's
talking about the 2016 election this was
on canadian television not many people
have seen this i think he'll be
surprised there was all this talk
of donald trump saying
if he loses it means the election is
rigged and all the media were saying no
no that's impossible you know take that
back you cannot say that about the
american republic
no election here could ever be rigged
that's impossible
and of course now they're saying the
exact opposite
that was in 2018. yeah so when the when
people say oh the right is politicizing
our institutions
keep in mind is anyone more frank is
anyone more transparent than norman
mcdonald
his whole joke was just saying what
things are yeah and at this point in
time he was pointing out remember in
2018 the democrats said the election was
rigged still they said that it was
stolen by the russians and big tech
didn't have a problem with you saying
that there are still thousands of videos
that you can find but if you suggest
that there's actual evidence of any kind
of voting irregularities or mail-in
voting flaws at any point which of
course we would never suggest ever you
wouldn't say that you get removed yeah
so there's norm right again
we'll miss that man uh by the way you
can follow us on instagram tiktok which
is where uh oh i hate that the chai
comes out
uh hey bring that up there quarterback
here why are you taking it away so we
don't have the
other thing it's thank you
and the best way to tune in live show
monday thursday 10am eastern that's the
best way to tune in watch this show
because notifications subscriptions may
not work uh and just comment below we're
gonna have a conversation with you on
all of these stuff and you may disagree
with us on the con go ahead and start it
up yeah we'll keep people disagree with
potito like i don't want i
no yeah or a very bad lawyer yes yeah
that's a good point
right
you're right
she but it's a nice or a bad police
officer who you know would pull them
over and be like oh what are you doing
swatting your boyfriend around all right
well we'll put him in a hotel and force
you to stay in a van that's what
happened with gabby patito a lot of
people don't know this
she was one night a domestically abusing
her boyfriend yeah some would argue had
enough
and they put him in a hotel in her in a
van
so there's a lot to this story
the main story here is the failure of
not only of course you see the federal
government the fbi our intelligence
agencies
but look i do people talk about back the
blue i don't think that most police
officers are going out and attempting to
try and violate your civil rights i
think some are however it still is a
bureaucratic wing of the government and
you cannot rely on them for your
personal safety and certainly the safety
of your family right that's the lesson
in this story we will go through all of
the missteps that you wouldn't have made
if you were taking control of your own
of your own safety before that this is
an article
from vox
wait wait there's still a thing there's
still a thing which by the way they'll
get mad they'll they'll accuse us of
being homophobic and going after this
again watch out
so there's this and it's like it's not
my fault that you're just so gay
it's on you
i don't even need to rebut a video i say
vox and people think
is it like folsom street fair no just
box
i'm just talking about vox
yay
i give you v
and the the noun of an animal that used
to plow fields and you immediately think
homosexual activity actually that's on
you and it rhymes with your favorite
meal yes
can't get enough
so this is something i spend a lot of
time and this is sometimes you guys
really help educate me
in that sometimes you know you're too
close to the forest to see the trees
right right yeah i think that's the term
something forest and trees and trees
it's about if you hear one fall yeah if
you hear one fall two birds a bush then
there's an asian clapping with one hand
something like that
pedophile i don't know but either way
someone's running a tub
so um
this vox article i spent all of this
time reading about this was about the
job market
and this is something that a lot of
talking heads are discussing on cnn on
cable news and it's really easy to get
lost in the weeds where they're talking
about well look there are more openings
than really ever in recent history and
wages have gone up but there's a
mismatch as far as experience so they're
talking about why people are looking to
hire but people aren't necessarily
taking these jobs and there's this whole
write-up
and i spent a good 25 minutes going
through it reading the other references
by the way all references for this show
available at loudspreader.com there's
like 50 a day yeah
and then i realized i didn't need to
read any of it
because there's a paragraph in here this
is about the mismatch of labor there's a
paragraph in this article at vox
again which goes on at least they use
this as a catalyst to say the government
needs to do a b c these programs these
types of free schooling these types of
job place it's just
a bunch of solutions
to a problem that is described in one
paragraph and this is something that i
want everyone out there to do as a
mental exercise
people use the term reductive so it's a
bad thing think of it as distillation
distillation is purification right i
want you to try and distill sometimes
very very complicated issues down to the
linchpin that matters most this is it in
the vox article how do we solve the
employment mismatch yeah it says some 46
percent of respondents said they were
only finding jobs that are low paying
while 41 percent said there weren't
enough openings in their preferred
profession [ __ ] you no unemployment no
benefits there it is almost half of
people like well this is not the exact
job i want then no no government program
to solve this problem you're an idiot
you're our problem is that 41 of
americans are effectively freshman in
college
i feel like you got this pissed off
reading it like 25 minutes in and you're
like son of a
day by 25 minutes wasting my time 46
respondents so they only find jobs that
are low paying and considering the
average hourly increase rate it's like
that's relative
only 18 an hour yeah yeah because you
have a degree in afrocentric feminism
that's a mighty good salary for someone
with a master's and afrocentrist
feminist yeah or you want to be an
influencer and you can't even influence
yourself to get a job yes
there's only there's only one way this
happens is if the federal government
overpays you to stay at home and they're
still fighting for continued
unemployment benefits above and beyond
what they normally give you you're
talking now about americans getting
checks how about this
find the people at least start with this
and i know it's not a lot because vox
doesn't probably have a huge sample size
find the people who make up the 41 who
said i won't take the job because it's
not my preferred position
and put them on a like a no-fly list to
never employ them
and never get any government benefits
this is this is where we are at this
point people we have a labor crisis no
no we really do 41 we have we have a we
have an entitlement crisis yeah
anyone out there your first job was it
exactly what you wanted
did you want to work for free and open
mics having beers thrown at you no i
loved it
yeah you catch me in your mouth
no i did way more jobs that sucked but
worse than that before that and it still
sucked quite a bit every job is it's a
job it's work entry-level jobs suck no
period yeah every one of these people
should have to work the graveyard shift
at taco bell there's no amount of money
that makes that seem acceptable even
though now it's probably starting at 20
hours it is it's like 14 or 15 the last
night i'll give you a signing bonus i
just keep laughing the more like
automated kiosks i see in fast food i'm
like you asked for it but yeah it is
funny though you just pull up and it's
like all right so when you're done with
the uh racial slurs and gay bashing you
would like a taco bell grande yeah
i don't know if i'm allowed to see taco
bell grande only you can say
taco bell grande maybe two soft tacos
and the jews control all the media yeah
also toss a vox in there that's too much
in there by the way you're looking at me
through the dress the joke is someone
else's being racist from the drugs have
you been to a taco bell have you ever
ordered there's police officers just
saying just sitting outside there like
they're hunting off a bait pile
it's
astonishing uh all right so look this is
just one of those things so you will
hear the media discussing how we solve
the labor problem
nope
doesn't exist
people don't want to work jobs that are
available there are plenty of jobs
available they pay well and not to
mention there are plenty of jobs
available that this require trades
training people don't want to do them
you
are entitled to the opportunity to work
you are not entitled to the job that you
want 41
41 can go screw yourself with a wire
brush all right get
nothing that'd be a good policy that's
some people's job yeah so now daniel
craig this is something that's been
making the rounds and it's very
clickbaity i want to be clear a lot of
headliners like he uh he said he doesn't
think a woman should play james bond the
truth is he was trying to respond in a
woke way so yeah i'm not condemning him
either way i think his response was
actually pretty reasonable however
because of the way the news cycle works
and because it's relatively slow and joe
biden has disappeared on vacation they
need something to talk about uh but it
still is interesting to see the response
from people so in an interview with the
radio times he explained daniel craig
why james bond shouldn't be played by a
woman and he said there should simply be
better parts for women and actors of
color why should a woman play james bond
when there should be a part just as good
as james bond but for a woman well how
about a non-crappy part because james
bond is not uh they've tried that it's
not the best film
no it's not really a it's like a dog
bringing you a dead bird and they think
like
you're like
no no i have no use for this said julia
roberts to
doctor know it's the wrong size
[Laughter]
there's a lot i couldn't think of a
current female star
they don't exist there's less police
academies and i enjoy them more yes
i want to see what this would look like
just watch atomic blonde you'll know
what i said this is not going they've
tried it multiple times it doesn't well
by the way we also we have an exclusive
uh we have exclusive audio so this was a
wrong interview an audio interview and
uh we actually have exclusive audio that
didn't didn't make the round and
surprised me no
so you really feel a woman shouldn't
play james bond see now you're you're
putting words in my mouth i uh i simply
said there shouldn't be parts uh well
there should be better parts for women
not just repackaging old roles that were
written for men yeah but
times are changing and bond is a great
role
i think woman should have a turn at
playing the greatest secret agent ever
yes because women are just so marvelous
at keeping secrets never mind what if a
female person of color played james
like an asian woman
well i suppose that'd be nice to see
james bond driving five under causing
endless fender benders what about a
black woman tenant was close enough so
why don't you just continue playing
james bond because i'm starting a new
wonder woman
oh wow
i'm surprised that didn't make the round
that's hypocritical kind of at the end
it is
yeah i mean i can't wait to see i don't
know if he's woke or anti-work it's like
tenant what's happening yeah you don't
get it it's backwards i know what that
does it's time look a couple couple of
things first off there should not be a
woman james bond doesn't work let me
explain to you why the whole point is
james bond is atypically charming and
that he's able to get women to sleep
with them right and pump them from
information the truth is it's usually a
skill set that most men don't have
myself not with standing i'm tall rich
and funny so i i have the hat trick but
i'm married later
but the point here is it's not
it's a man trying to get women to sleep
with him he's charming enough a woman
just needs to say yes you remove half
the dynamic of james bond and there have
been plenty of female spies of course it
doesn't work because they're physically
the weaker of the sex also uh you know
the movies just aren't very good but
more important is they say we need a
black i have no problem
with a black james bond as long as it's
the girl who played precious right no oh
what but the issue he wants go super
woke up why do you mean
a black james bond this is the issue
when people talk about it's like you're
injecting race where it doesn't need to
be let me just say this one thing
this is one area when people talk about
it black james bond
there is no lack of representation of
black american men in the action hero
genre if you were to have will smith at
his peak right will smith men in black
independence day and run it opposite a
james bond vehicle on the same weekend
will smith would have decimated it will
smith denzel washington for crying out
loud they tried to sell us jamie foxx as
an action hero [ __ ] shaq there are
plenty of black male action heroes
richard rowntree is and will always be
the only chef he will only anybody
yeah yeah well i look i think it makes
sense to have a black james bond i don't
i don't have a problem with it because
you're pulling from makes zero
oh where is this pie i don't know the
only not white thing in whole
peripherals yeah it's not good when it's
like we're going to need you to be at
the bowl and ready to meet our contact
at 11 43 and then they're like guys it's
1 30.
where is our spy look the the the script
would have to change a little granted no
but i think you did you turned my
ferragamos into a phone yeah
what the [ __ ] i have to do to my watch
what the what is my what in my car i
can't you you look i can't see the plate
on the car you know what's gonna happen
with five oh i'll get pulled over for
that [ __ ] i can't do that [ __ ] dropping
spikes and [ __ ] i ain't no i don't roger
more moon rape [ __ ] and the
problem is then he's going to take out
the the anti-aircraft guns to put in
subwoofers hit the button yeah look i
didn't say chris
turbo just plays drake i don't know
he's just sitting in a bar you hear a
building explode and he's like is it
wednesday
look we didn't say put chris rock in the
roll okay like he's not gonna be that
guy chris tucker idris albert rock
tucker either way
but i'm going to go with he would i
think yourself was great it would be a
good job my point is here it's they make
it has to be it doesn't have to be in my
issue they say well we need better
representation this is an issue where
it's pretty equal yeah it's pretty equal
i mean look james bond was you're
talking about fleming you go back to
broccoli you go back to the history it's
just it's a white guy spy spying on
white people i know i mean but there's
other countries he can go to there's a
whole part of the world
yeah yeah this is something that's gonna
happen if i was a woman though i would
be offended by this i'm like oh so you
can't create anything for us that makes
sense for us that fits like you just
have to shoehorn us into them like why
aren't they pissed off about that that
they're being shoehorned into a male
role and it doesn't work if james bond
were a woman it would just be
she'd just be a [ __ ]
that's true you'd be like well james
bond is a male horse
yes exactly but you know what that's my
pleasure right if you know what's called
notches on your bed post because usually
the response from women by the way this
is someone who has talked about not
having sex with my woman until we were
married i advocate abstinence and i
actually think that we have a problem
with degeneracy in the culture so let's
be really clear here but it's not just
on a bed post because the most likely
response if a man tries to court a woman
to copulate with her is no i i got a lot
of help do you know the response to any
man if you're a female secret spy
it's going
basically the request is just come on
that's it unless it's lizzo i mean well
at least you're going to have a spy
though you're gonna have a pregnancy
for when they're carrying lockjaw's baby
it's just injecting this where it
doesn't need to be i i don't know look
you guys can come i would be very
surprised if black americans were
sitting around going well i can't
believe we don't have a black james bond
what the [ __ ]
i don't think that matters i agree i
think casino royale's like can he you
guys got to tell him to stop playing
slot machines and when he wins
he's just yelling like it's saying
really it's just he's drawn attention
look there's nickels there's a there's a
dynamic with poker it's about reading
someone in their tell he's you can't
just go in with your state lottery
ticket
hey man he just yelled full house mother
effort
and domino
supposed to be undercover what's going
on
those are mahjong tablets this is not
domino where have you learned
domino's poker mr bingo [ __ ]
he's outside with some of the like
waiters just playing dice
he wins a baby yeah i mean look for the
same reason what for the same reason
that shaft couldn't it couldn't have
been roger moore going into harlem yeah
could you imagine like look this is the
whole it's a cult it's a uk culture at a
moment in time and it's totally fine and
i have no problem with address elba
being james bond my point is it has to
be a woman and then they start with
needs to be a woman of color well really
they start with needs to be an lgbtq
woman of color who's part native
american and has rickets and then they
scale it back and go all right we'll
just take uh a you know a gay black guy
and you're like okay i guess james brown
always should have been a big gay black
guy well my issue is
is when they shoehorn halle berry into
uh a james bond movie they also shoot
horner into john wick and when they do
that you're like
yeah it's just your response because
it's not the same thing right it's like
i don't want to see charlie's angels
with three dudes there's a reason why
it's three it's three ass kicking chicks
yeah and the other way around like with
black people
we didn't want like a white leader in
black panther like we're not trying to
take over these roles so just make it
just work that we weren't looking at the
fountain fights and dynasty going that
should be bill burr in there
why not no judas what you guys gonna
throw okay you're gonna throw me the
fountain now right because i'm not not
[ __ ] uh not rich like you okay all
right now i'm gonna found now who could
have seen this one coming
all right
yeah judas and the black messiah would
have been a lot different with the
panthers if the guy infiltrating it was
white yeah
wait could you speak into my lapel of
what your
they're showing him on the security
guard this is not you shaft he's like i
can't watch myself all right you shoot
him in the foot
[Laughter]
so anyway the point is i this is this is
absurd but this isn't there this is a
constant theme of injecting race and
gender into somewhere it doesn't need to
be and then people focus on that and
they focus on these chasms that we have
in identity politics and you miss
you miss the actions that you can take
in your day-to-day life to improve it
and improve the lives of those in your
community and you know what also improve
your relationships with people of other
sexes i don't use genders uh other sexes
and other races
you want to know what black people think
don't read what vox says yeah go talk to
someone i will say this we talk the
other day uh i've had far more pleasant
interactions lately with black americans
than white feminists
oh yeah of course they're so much
friendlier like i was friends with black
people yeah they
would go hey how you doing and you know
yeah you know the other day i just said
you know these guys who were actually
working they were painting yeah in a
garage next door is how you doing man i
was carrying a bunch of stuff said it
looks heavy you need a hand and i said
no you know i should probably do it
myself i know who that i know how that
is i said how are you doing you know
just keep an eye
i'm like i never talk with white people
they don't even white people don't ask
me how i'm doing
culture you're absolutely right they've
completely we've completely eliminated
the idea of neighbors now you have
people complaining like well this guy's
going to come into our country it's like
you haven't even met the flanagans next
door right what do you care about
they're calling on you because your lawn
is three inches tall
and they call the cops they don't even
address you directly right you report
them to homeland security for their maga
bumper sticker
porches again i'm with you though if i
see a movie coming out usually i'm much
more interested in a black action movie
i like i love john equalizer dude
equalizer or as i call it black taken
far superior film really great to take
in honestly
yeah but it is it's equalizer's a better
movie i got a particular set of skills
right right right
you got skills i got skills we both got
skills i got a particular set of skills
uh he's the best actor but yeah it is
amazing he can do anything else it's
just i have no other skills i can't sing
or dance the point is james bond is
white
black guys are tougher than white guys
in general
and denzel's best action she's great
we're okay with man on fire come on guys
oh yeah that's pretty good that's to be
honest that's the one where he shoves
the bomb up the guy's ass or is that out
of time
that one's out of time that one's out of
time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah shoves it i've seen
it yeah he does yeah he shoves the guy
wakes up and he's like he's like you
know about two minutes that bombs about
i wish you had more time and the guy's
like what and
oh my ass
that's not what he says
i always said that he's got the acme bag
cartoon he dies very quickly oh it blew
my underwear off yeah
it blew my underwear off with not a
streak of blood because we needed to
make sure that this was pg-13 for the
test screen this is dusty
all right
so speaking of racists and i mean
racists and race baiters absolutely and
that's what i want to talk about today
uh i believe that these people are
racist okay and i mean that by the
definition that they see everything
through the lens of race and they
believe that we should be divided by
race and in some instances they believe
that people uh enjoy the moral high
ground or superior position exclusively
because of their race
let me that's my preset position let me
explain so a few days back uh
before we get to uh petito michael eric
dyson
joined joy reid here to discuss the
fallout and i just want to leave this in
because then joy reid discussed potito
but it's a pattern of behavior they were
discussing the fallout of nicki minaj's
anti-vaxx which really isn't what
happened uh comments here we go nicki
minaj says when i go out on tour i'm
gonna get back because i gotta do it
i understand the hesitancy one listen i
was hesitant when donald trump was out
there controlling the cdc and
controlling the fda and manipulating
them and making them put out falsehoods
anybody rational was hesitant but the
reality is now
what we what i really fear is masses of
more masses of people dying 666 000
people have died and disproportionately
they look like you and me
fat
[Music]
statistically overweight i believe
that's correct
oh you wanted me to be racist like you
you want to say people who look like you
and me and the first thing that i see
not be the double chins
well here's an idea you're right by the
time you have a guest that's black you
don't immediately turn ghetto
did you notice that about that show yeah
there's like i got the bag no no i don't
want to [ __ ] no mouth what
what what were you saying
uh no seriously look
they're talking about black people being
vaccine hesitant yeah i think and
they're trying to say people who look
like us so the presumption there is
people who look like us well
the average american should be able to
watch that and see
a multitude
of factors that should be taken into
consideration
okay do you mean do you mean the double
chin do you mean people who are near
shader do you mean the the the skrillex
hairdo that changes with every single
clip what do you mean what are we
talking about we talking the maybelline
counter are we talking about the sun
dresses are we talking about people who
host shows no it's just what obviously
it means black yeah
and the issue here is look
over obesity is an issue and listen i'm
not joy reid is not that big but big
enough michael eric dyson is i mean he's
pudding
and let's be clear you if you are under
the age of 3 18 you are three times more
likely to be hospitalized with covet you
have one and a half times higher the
rate of severe illness yeah if you're
overweight yeah if you're overweight it
is the single biggest contributing
preventable factor to covid let me ask
you this we don't have these numbers do
you believe
do you believe that you are safer being
obese and vaccinated than you are being
unvaccinated
and fit and healthy
that's a question everyone has to ask
themselves
you can do both
but you do have to determine what is
most important if we're talking about
functioning as a society yeah is it
being fit being healthy placing an
emphasis on that or placing an emphasis
on ultimately what gets pfizer 19
billion dollars in q2 ah some would say
that's a lot of money you know it's
interesting the way that she put that
she said you know and these 666 000 by
the way round it up you know that's just
a weird number six six six i don't know
hearing that yeah why don't you do that
she's saying and they look like us she
also didn't have to stamp it on her well
that's true yeah she scans it
oh not yet okay it's actually a birth
mark it's not her fault no she got
whose fault is she actually saying that
that is that people that look like them
i know that she means black right whose
fault is she saying that is because
she's not saying that it's their fault
she's saying oh somebody wait a second
is this a trick question because i
believe the answer was in that
asinine statement where she said of
course anyone logical should have been
vaccine hesitant when it was trump oh
oh so what you mean is that when donald
trump did operation warp speed before we
developed the trump vaccine whether you
like it or not it's the trump vaccine
yep you along with kamala harris along
with joe biden right along with nancy
pelosi said that you would not take the
vaccine that you couldn't possibly trust
it and now you're saying it's the fault
of angry white of angry women no it's
you you're the reason you told them not
to trust it yeah because you created you
want to divide people by race and create
a race war now you're single people who
look like us my mistake i assume we were
talking about fact it's creating a fake
uh
a fake fault though you're blaming
something that you just want to have to
be there to be the bad guy right as
opposed to just saying it's their
personal choice and right now they don't
trust it for whatever reason they don't
all things why would black americans not
trust the federal government being there
to help i can't imagine don't they get
the 200 a month to raise their babies
right
come on that's 50 for the mortgage
80 for food
i always loved this argument though like
donald trump
it's just so stupid they have every
individuals have an individual reason
not to take the vaccine and the only
pers people who i see smashing it
together are black news shows saying
this is the exact reason you don't go
yeah no no it's not you don't know
everybody you don't know everybody but
there's a good chance that uh they were
listening to you yeah yeah
yeah your criticism of donald trump like
he's the guy down there making like with
the beakers and stuff making the vaccine
like that's not what was happening it
was scientists but it is because of
donald trump who removed the red tape
that we have the vaccine that everyone
wants to praise now and you all said
that you wouldn't trust or take the
vaccine just like we played the norm
clip where they said that the 2016
election was stolen by the russians and
then big tech banned anyone who said
that there could be any type of
interference in an election right let's
be really clear about this [ __ ]
timeline here because i'm getting really
tired of it and the point that i'm going
to make to you is don't buy any of it
pardon my language sorry but the issue
here is we have the 2016 election okay
the democrats try and front load it and
say oh that's going to get going to be
rigged you just saw a clip of nor
macdonald talking about in 2018 in that
context at that moment in time like a
time capsule saying hey
of course democrats right they're saying
that we can't sit at the institutions
but right now they're saying they were
saying that the election was rigged that
was all over the news right the russia
lie the conspiracy then 2020 comes along
and big tech says you can't talk about
the election being rigged at all you
can't even talk about voter fraud
occurring on a small scale because it
might
so distrust in our institutions so the
stuff that democrats said for three
years you can't say now let's fast
forward to vaccinations the entire
last year of donald trump's presidency
kamala harris joe biden nancy pelosi joy
these people were showing distrust
saying don't trust the vaccine you
absolutely cannot trust the vaccine
because donald trump wants to give money
to his big rich friends and big farmer
campaign campaign finance reform the one
percent they were doing this for a year
now they want to mandate that you all
take it and ask why you don't trust it
and again big tech removes anyone for
saying today what they said one year ago
one year ago
they didn't remove joy reid
they didn't remove rachel maddow for
saying don't they didn't remove kamala
harris were saying do not trust the
vaccine but they will remove us if we
say hey you know what the vaccine
doesn't immunize you it protects you
from serious illness but that's not the
bill you were sold a reasonable critique
of bureaucracy and the issue with the
vaccine that all of you know everyone
knows including people who've been
vaccinated and have not been vaccinated
you are not allowed to say but for a
year and a half they were allowed to
unfettered go out and convince black
people that the federal government was
trying to sterilize them you can find
those clips because they're still up
[Music]
wow but it's a different fact oh wait no
it's the same
one by the way that was a good alex
jones that was that was good
and the thing is and also the vaccines
they're making the frogs guy look i was
going i was look i was down by like
travis i saw uh i saw frog okay
he was humping a coke and it was one of
those rainbow issue coke hands for gay
pride i knew that that frog
does alex look into it though
no look there's no conspiracy here's the
thing too with conspiracies
this is my litmus test with conspiracies
okay
because people come forward and they go
oh and the jews in this and that are
areas fifteen okay look the first you
don't have enough time to debunk every
conspiracy okay
so your first litmus test is
who's they in this conspiracy how many
people have to be involved for this
conspiracy to take part if it includes
everyone from the top down with the
highest security clearance at the
pentagon as well as the intern and the
janitor probably doesn't hold water but
let me tell you this right now when we
were talking about the fact that there
was a narrative going on for years that
the election was rigged from russia
and then every single person was banned
or pieces of content were banned for
saying hey maybe we need to uh just like
elizabeth warren and just like amy
klobuchar and just like brady cena's
focus on election security who needs to
be involved with that okay the same
amount of people who need to be involved
with they when we're talking about
don't trust the vaccine
donald trump is wrong do not trust this
vaccine and then
the vaccine is entirely safe there are
zero side effects you have to take it we
need to support a mandate who needs to
be involved and they'll ban anyone who
says anything
to the opposite effect of that who is
they you're talking about really ten
people you're talking about the
president you're talking about heads of
the fda the cdc and then just the top of
big tech who say yeah sure in other
words the president
fauci a few people at the fda say let's
just make sure that everyone agrees with
this line on uh on the back and anyone
who criticizes it is removed and you
have zuckerberg susan wojcicki jack
dorsey maybe two other people who say
good marching orders you're talking
about six to ten people who need to be
involved as they i don't think that's a
conspiracy i think it's happening in
front of your eyes what can you do
nothing
nothing as well what i mean to say is
nothing for them
don't give an inch oh i don't care about
the masks yes you do no one can force
you to wear a mask
oh as if the vaccine is no
not saying don't take the vaccine don't
feel forced to take the vaccine
because now you end up with a place like
australia where you have to you're going
to have to take the cops
we'll se they have an app yeah just talk
about this jordan peterson they will
send you a text you have to take a
picture
within 15 minutes to show them
that you are where they demand you be or
they can come and arrest you
just right we just saw yesterday
protesters in australia in the streets
being shot by uh police officers and it
was it was a uni union who was upset the
union police officer so whoever win
whoever loses we we all win but yeah
either way it ends up working out it's a
good thing that those australians had
their guns banned or that could get out
of control oh yeah they're going to end
up in a kangaroo court oh
thank you oh dave that's where they make
you fight a kangaroo yeah got a raise
it's no shark jail that's for sure no
shark chips well they shark jail oh but
no they have great accommodations that
they've built they're they're called
quarantined right yeah they're called
they're still different name for it you
know you're gonna pack people into
railroad cards and sell them there too
i'm sorry i'm making that reference but
anytime you build an encampment
somewhere and force people to go there
bad stuff tends to happen they're
telling them and they're not gonna be
finished until two years from now it's
also planning it long term i also
thought it was distasteful that they
were asking people if you were haitian
that's a little weird yeah that was i
was like well then it comes with a bull
whip
also known as horse rain yeah your
government is here to help also the gold
fillings collector was a bit much it was
a little bit a little bit yeah you don't
need to do that
it's just insane though yeah the fact
that they are building it for two years
from now it feels like this isn't gonna
stop and like you were saying with the
masks there's only one reason to wear a
mask fear that's it it's different kinds
of fear it might be afraid of the person
next to you getting angry afraid of a
cold whatever it might be but it's fear
yeah that's why you're wearing it bottom
line there's no other reason you have
people right now in this country who are
forbidding their family from attending
their weddings if they're not vaccinated
yeah you have places like australia
where the police can
force you to download an app track your
whereabouts demand that you send them a
picture within 15 minutes or they come
and arrest you
arrest you if you violate curfew walking
your dog right these are things that are
happening across the globe i need to ask
you
do you really think that's not
scarier than a than a virus with a
significantly less than one percent
mortality rate
getting shot if you want to go outside
that sounds like that that sounds like a
shot if you want to go well no that's
just but i mean in australia that's
essentially it just i just want everyone
out there to stop force them to fire you
yeah that's don't comply
don't comply at all don't give an inch
anymore because look how far we've gone
i think we're that frog in boiling water
right now you want to sit and go wait
hold on a second hold on a second
we're all talking right now and everyone
i can sense it in you and i can say
you're afraid that this is going to be
banned or removed for us saying
something that is more scientifically
backed and is more reasonable than what
joy reid was espousing
five months ago
and we live in fear saying you know what
vaccine might be leaky with the delta
varian
well
what we're going to be banned for saying
there's a study involving 25 000 people
in both categories at the [ __ ] mayo
clinic that shows moderna the vaccine
has a 42
efficacy rate
with the with the delta varied and we
need to be afraid of being removed
meanwhile
black female i assume black z joy reed
alex jones the black equivalent of alex
jones is telling people that donald
trump might be contaminating the vaccine
but now there's joe biden you should
trust it and we have to worry about
citing studies
and data
this is a cr
no more leeway none yeah that's what
terrifies me a lot though about doing
this show because it doesn't make sense
to me where we live in a free country
everybody wants to have a conversation
you're allowed to have an open dialogue
and we just want to say our opinions and
kind of get to the bottom of something
and we're worried that that's going to
be taken down how does that make any
sense it's because it led to violence on
january 6. remember this is what this
pivots on right it led to violence and
so therefore we can't have speech that
leads to violence
what in the world do you think was going
on before black lives matter protests
started breaking out and we had violence
in almost every major american city
across the country you didn't say a word
for that you didn't stop any of that
stuff going out fiery but mostly just
january 6th gerald
i've been burning cars since i was like
eight yeah well just for warmth yeah and
all for fun
eat a little bit of cola
come on i like to go
i want to make sure there's people
sleeping in them you know what i mean oh
cause they're dead already what happened
in seattle you don't know it's a detroit
thing ah okay yeah if you knew you're
from detroit if you watched it follows
you wouldn't know yeah watch it follows
it's very detroit it really is so don't
breathe yeah you watch it you go oh
oh yeah that's absolutely detroit like
they saved they cut costs hey by the way
thanks again democrats you've been in
control of that city since 1961 you know
most wealthiest city in the world until
you got your hands on it oh [ __ ]
yourselves you know it's the scariest
part of don't breathe the neighborhood
yeah yeah
yes like don't you just like in that
film yeah where at the sorry spoiler
alert he lets the rottweiler out and the
rottweiler seems to be running through a
cornfield you know that's urban detroit
oh that's downtown detroit and it's
completely desolate well
what i also love is uh the police
response time the whole movie's about
you know a blind guy killing people and
all you know in his basement and then
you watch it and like somebody calls the
cops and they're coming and you're like
that's the most unbelievable
it would be three days later they
knocked on the door like is this still a
problem yeah anybody alive why'd you
take
we were coming here but then we came
across a bear yeah
that the fire yeah that's some damage at
the renaissance center have you been
downtown
we saw a lion with a pierced ear and
uh movie studios love it
post-apocalyptic scene they don't even
have to make it anymore well and that's
a stupid state who decided let's not
give them tax breaks yeah you had new
hollywood there because it was you know
all ruined it was a white cat then
they're like no we're not giving you the
tax breaks like they're going to go oh
well we wanted to stay in detroit right
we'll go to georgia bye they're like
really we you understand that we'll just
build a shipwreck for pirates of the
caribbean nine you just happen to have a
bunch of dead wood just everywhere we
were going to inject 19 million dollars
into your economy michigan but uh oh
okay i see how this is there's a yacht
club at belle isle that looks like it's
ran by pirates
for people who don't know detroit is an
absolute cr and it is entirely due to
leftist politics yeah completely
unfettered if joy reid had her way
uh or barack obama or joe biden's
administration it would look like
detroit detroit would be utopia you want
to know what it looks like 1961 to today
detroit there's a segment on it i'll put
a link in the description i did this
12 years ago yeah yeah all right let's
get on to gabby potito uh
going back to joy reid joy reid the
racist
uh
of course she has a race angle on the
gabby patina here you go oh
but the way this story has captivated
the nation has many wondering why not
the same media attention when people of
color go missing
the answer actually has a name missing
white woman syndrome okay that you made
by the late and great gwen eiffel to
describe the media we haven't been able
to find the nation with missing white
women like lacey peterson or natalie
holloway while ignoring cases involving
missing people of color okay like every
day in chicago yeah and lacie was also
four houses down
it's a real slop job this is also
something that is
look
she's banking on you and this is the
problem too with what we do right and
you guys can look in the comment section
matter of fact i want you to engage
right now just just ask a question and i
want you guys to host some debates here
in the comment section because you'll
see that a lot of the people who watch
this right now and this is open source
not mug club of course we take your
private chats at leadwithcredit.com mug
club where we have to take into account
that a lot of you watch other
programming yeah that a lot of you lean
left
or that a lot of you are going to hold
our feet to the fire and you absolutely
should that a lot of you will be
checking our references we can check the
click-through rates from our youtube
links to the website many of you go to
use the references and we always
encourage you to joy reid
right now is assuming that none of her
audience has heard information from
another source
because do you know how i know that the
most popular podcast
serial was about jaimin lee a lady of
color
yep
they don't care they don't care when
it's a minority
really
joyride doesn't have anyone around her
in her ear just saying
huh
wait i just i just heard that cereal
what else what else do we have here uh
elisa lamb the folk the vanishing at the
ceso hotel yeah festering pile of [ __ ]
the documentary it was a horrible
documentary
it starts the cecil hotel you see an
asian lady in an elevator who looks
whacked out of her mind on drugs and
you're like oh this is a lady freaking
out hallucinating on drugs and then they
take you through an entire series like
was it drugs spoiler at the end she was
on drugs
[Music]
there's no ghosts you seem very angry
well did you watch the series he has the
right to be angry yeah
there's a whole episode just on skid row
and you're like what is this okay yeah i
feel like we need it it was like
that series held me down on a pinball
machine did richard ramirez just living
in the hotel at the time and she got
killed by a hot water tank
that's unacceptable
so we're just going through the tunnel
very sad story let me give you some
other oh no yeah it's super super sad or
whatever
the seattle times and the sunday even
compared to lisa lam to the gabby petito
case now she mentions native americans
let's get in first off how about you
stop again seeing everyone is nothing
but their race but this is the issue joy
reid has to yeah assume that everyone
who views her program is as racist as
she is um
there are cultural differences
as well so let's let's talk about
cultural differences that may
may actually if we want to talk about
solutions within these communities not
just brow beat and go white people
aren't doing enough for the indigenous
community first off that's a stupid term
we used to say indigenous then we had to
say native american i don't know where
you went back on the rule
but i think the the the skrillex hair
glue is getting to your brain it makes
no sense you can't say indigenous
are you not supposed to aboriginal no no
redskins no now oh two four nine
day drinkers
yes no no moving on what accurate the uh
you know the just the the race of uh the
the the the people who were here who
lack the genetic processing enzyme to
process fire water yes that's all yeah
those people i say my native friend and
his his name is spotted bear i'm not
even joking really yeah and uh he said
savages is what they don't like to be
called really like just the white guy i
love to be called a savage well i don't
mind
when i say savage i never connected it
though to a native american yeah well i
always just connected it to somebody
behaving like a caveman yeah you know
but i guess savage is their word that
they think is kind it's their
n-word if you will well you know what
look and i understand that too and if
that they should have probably avoided
scalping women and children well they
kind of walked into that one i mean we
did some stuff bad we did
let's
call it a wash mutual that's fair yeah
yeah okay okay
um your casino has taken tons of yeah
ruined plenty of lives
look we get it sorry smallpox blankets
but now you have nyquil
right thank you energy take the good
with the bad that's the facts of life
there you go great owl so native
american here's the thing tribal police
often underfunded
often under trained um
look there's also what we're talking she
talks about native americans there's a
whole this is a we don't have time for
this when you look at actually tribal
police what goes on there but it's very
similar to the black american community
there's an anti-snitching culture which
by the way is a big reason that you have
vaccine hesitancy right now in the black
community it's not something that can be
scientifically studied in a poll but
when you're asking people to report to a
flight attendant or to report to
homeland security a neighbor for not
wearing a mask or to report them so that
someone can go door to door to encourage
them to take a vaccine that doesn't
really go over too well with members of
the black community for reasons that you
say you've understood when you actually
falsify uh these examples of systemic
oppression i'm not saying that your
examples of systemic oppression are
correct but i am saying there have
definitely been historical examples that
would give black people pause uh in
trusting government workers door-to-door
hey can we find common ground there oh
that's right you're racist
so the no snitching culture yeah yeah
you could get black snitch you could sh
you could shoot someone in the street
they're not gonna call the cops
it's just the response time what do i
mean by this bro i mean a lot of black
people in the community i mean listen to
any uh any uh hip-hop album from the 90s
there you go pretty clear yeah oh yeah
it made a lot of sense pick a random
track there's something else too that
she's really kind of glossing over like
you know these these big stories kind of
take over the media every once in a
while i think a lot of it has to do with
there's not really much else going on
right now nothing that's really so she
has to say this is a racist thing well
no that's what i'm saying like i think
this has taken hold because there's
there's kind of some texture to this
story they were traveling around there's
video footage of them being pulled over
there's kind of this mystery of what's
actually going on but there's not a lot
like i guarantee you something else pops
in the news and this story basically
goes to page six like it's done right i
have a question here joy
you're a host
of a news channel
you can do it yeah let's see how many
others
this you're
holy crap
holy crap quarterback where'd that come
from perfect it's like oh yeah
why don't you be the change you want to
see in the world
yeah look at the man in the mirror joy i
mean i get that you're not really you
know fox news or joe rogan or this
program but still you have more you have
more of them of an audience share than
the guy with funyuns on his couch really
you're pointing at him you're pointing
at the guy who found you in a hotel
incidentally to fix racial
discrimination yeah
really really you have your own show and
you're not even giving it the effort you
think that the guy at la quinta stopped
over and schenectady has a shot
you remember she made this point she's
got two million followers all right sure
to say nicki minaj thing you've got 22
million girl you've got a plan you don't
have a platform with 2 million followers
i'm surprised national television well
i've seen a lot of amber alerts that i i
would say definitely tell you that
you're on the looking for different
races and i'm just trying to be honest
no it's true i've ignored it all i have
many amber alerts have different races
yes i i ignore all kind either which way
i'm like could you with this buzzing
stop yeah um
that's honestly that car could be next
to me and i wouldn't know amber alert
just reminds me to get a flip phone no
clue
why do you want to pull the box i'm
tired of these kidnapping messages
about the actual kidnappings but
i will agree for a long time there it
was almost a joke that a lot of the
times when a white girl would disappear
usually a girl in a neighborhood that
was more well to do it would make the
news it would be all over the place and
i think it's because honestly it was a
more rare story than the violence that
was going on in other neighborhoods
there is a point to it i mean i think
we've all we
we've all seen it we've all kind of
agreed with it to some degree at least i
have in my life i've noticed it yeah but
yeah you can change it that's that's not
the reason that doesn't know is a story
right now no and that's what i mean and
that doesn't take that doesn't mean
anything right now if you want to help
find the boyfriend who they were like
look we're going to put you at the four
seasons yes
this is punishment now oh well i haven't
gotten to those facts a little bit of
facts oh sorry but no but it is true i
just think it's pointless to bring it up
now when if you want to do something
help well and also now this is
the problem is we have far more examples
of the media jumping on stories that
involve people who are minorities
without getting the full story in order
to try and stir up racial division
correct um like jacob blake for example
it's like oh hold on how about you use
how about these women aren't just seen
as a pawn
for what about the woman when jacob
blake you know he went back she had a
restraining order went back to the house
stole the kids reached for a knife under
the floorboard and you talked about the
injustice of the cops shooting him why
don't you care about the black woman
there who actually did the right thing
and went to the authorities and filed a
restraining order it's the point is all
of this is politics with this these
people and you don't need to do it you
don't need to play the game anymore when
someone says oh why are why gabby petite
are you interested because she's uh are
you interested because she's white and
you're racist you know what you do
people say oh already nope
that's it
and they won't and that screws their
whole plan
but we were expecting you to say yes but
even somebody like natalie holloway look
at that that was corruption in other
countries they allowed a judge's son to
kill her and then kill someone else in a
hotel in like peru i think yeah i don't
know the rules but i know that the kim
jong-un brother cousin where they went
up and did the prank show do you ever
see that one no oh my god you guys don't
know this okay we'll talk about it okay
all right remind me okay let me write
this down we got it we got to get
through this
cousin
comment do you guys know the story
how kim jong-un had his cousin or his
brother they can find him in the control
and had him killed it was either cousin
or the brother i knew he they convinced
these girls they were on a game show and
they were like going up behind people at
the airport just like oh guess who and
then people like get your hands over me
and then they had they gave these women
you got to tell them my club my club
save it this was on a show like no no no
this actually happened this is how kim
jong-un had one of his
relatives murdered that was like a
practical joke it but it involves a
practical joke show
with ricin like oh look at the camera
over there and over there no one knew
that you don't know this story
and the point is those people were
minorities not where they were killed
they're the majority but to us they're
minorities all right
so there's some truth to what joy is
saying obviously remember all those
peaceful protests and the name of uh you
know in the name of exclusively white
women oh wait [ __ ] and then if you just
turn to your right our photographer
spike demas is going to get you the
other cruiser that one is almost
finished burning
got a lot another one then
those cars were racist that's what you
don't know yeah the people who lit those
fires were next stop loobies
but they were pintos
and what about the riots for daniel
shaffer tony timpa uh kelly thomas all
white people killed by the cops oh yeah
none
almost exactly with tempa almost exactly
like george floyd yeah right it was
almost exactly the same and i just again
jacob blake was a situation that we
covered here what do you want to do what
do you want to do to protect this black
woman here who did who did the right
thing which by the way that is we talk
about brave it's brave for a black woman
to go to the cops and follow a
restraining order against a man who's
violent with her yes because he's
violent with her he's already shown a
proclivity for violence and b she might
be ostracized by her community again
because of the non-snitching culture
that's a brave
step to take and you didn't support her
he said the cops were racist when they
showed up to protect her on violent
attempt number two three or four by the
way so this wasn't a one-time incident
and by the way reach for a knife to try
and stab the cops uh so let's go through
gabby potato really quickly in august uh
they were pulled over
here's something important to note too
this has been mishandled too instead of
seeing this through the prism of race
see it through the lens
see it for what it is
government bureaucracy is incredibly
inefficient incredibly ineffective and
because it cannot protect you is
dangerous if you are living your life
relying on a police response time to
save you if you're living your life
relying on a central intelligence agency
to keep you safe
you are living an unsafe life you are
taking a risk that you do not need to
take
and i'm not saying that we know exactly
what happened with this situation what
i'm saying is there are steps that you
can take yourself
to avoid being a victim and it starts by
understanding that the government cannot
help you or save you and unfortunately
the government as you see in australia
comes in to control you they're more
interested in controlling you than
helping you so we'll go through what
happens here with patito and all the
missteps um she was pulled over
august her fiance brian laundry
um and i think we have the clip they
were pulled over for speeding but she
was clearly in distress this should have
been a red flag here
yeah i don't know it's just
some days
really bad ocd and i just
i was just cleaning and fading up back
the them before and i was apologizing to
him and saying i'm sorry that i'm so
mean we really had a nice morning
but um she just kind of worked up
because we were trying to get going and
get our day going because we want to go
um like argentina
you want to tell me about those
scratches on your face she hit himself
on her hand that's why i was pushing her
away because i
see she wanted i like the keys so i
could walk away i said let's just take a
breather and let's not
be clear she was being physically
violent with him that's what this report
is about right now she had her phone he
was trying to get the pieces
i know i've seen a question i was just
trying to push her away to go let's
let's just take a minute step back and
breathe and
see if she got me
you want to tell me about hitting that
curve
hitting the curve with her grabbing the
wheel did she grab the wheel yeah she
said i can't leave again fold over
here so um oh wow to be clear about this
too
laundry was listed as the victim in the
police report so this is a matter of
record we have the sources of
atlatlskinder.com um
instead of charging gabby petito with
domestic violence
they put him in a hotel and her in a van
for the night now here's a point okay
this is the problem with not holding
people accountable for their actions
whether the black white men or women
right a woman commits domestic violence
here she should be treated the same as a
man had the roles been reversed and that
man abused gabby petitto guess what
would have been arrested and the
scenario wouldn't have continued yeah i
don't and i i don't want to make this
claim but i don't know if they had seen
a woman with a bloodied face if she
would have had any say in the arrest
happening no usually it doesn't matter
whether they want to press charges at
all it would be like hey we're taking
you into custody and maybe they end up
releasing them later but they have to i
think i don't know somebody can somebody
can comment and tell us that in other
words had the had this bureaucratic wing
of the police had they treated her the
way she should have been treated just
like if she were a man as opposed to
lower standards
arrest
and there that stops us from heading on
down the trail to the tragedy that we've
seen but instead it was ah she's a woman
she just she just pulled the wheel
she just hit you
i was just driving her out to the middle
of the desert officer
i can't believe the reason she's like
i'm pissed that you're getting pulled
you do wonder the sequence of events at
this point
if he was like ah yeah they had like a
picnic uh blanket in the back and
flowers then she kept jerking the wheel
he's like oh well this trip just took
this this just changed
the plans have changed i'm not i'm not
shocked she'd pull the wheel and i'm
just gonna say do you think the blonde
white girl has had the same run-ins with
the law that that fella has she doesn't
know that jerking the wheel making it
worse is gonna really matter yeah it's
not matter i'm sorry but that's the
truth this is all
the reason why they were able to she was
able to be let off is because it is a
stereotype yeah they assumed everything
was fine she was crying
yeah she's crying she's like i have ocd
which is why i tried to claw his eyes
out
it's fine yes i was just cleaning and
punching him and they're like i get it i
have to turn a life switch on and off 16
times before i enter a room and also
kick him in the testicles repeatedly
it's just
it's my illness
and i i just kick him in the balls and
say you're gonna have goof babies over
and over again
but i think this will end well so all
right go ma'am
then brian returned to florida in the
van without gabby monday the fbi uh
covered her body tragic obviously this
is a surprise to everybody um it's not a
surprise to anyone well no but i'm
saying it's it's
yeah
they only found a body though because it
was these family travel vloggers who
spotted her van in their own youtube
video yeah so let's be clear the police
didn't find the police didn't find them
the fbi didn't find them and this is
what i'm when when we had uh uh
i believe it was in salt lake city utah
antifa hand us
an ice pick and went to their car to go
get a sawed-off shotgun this is before
andy no this is where anyone else
infiltrated antifa we were doing it as
just a segment um
they actually gave us weapons and they
were planning on attacking ben shapiro
right you can go and watch this if it's
not removed it may be removed from
youtube it may be on facebook you can go
see it at mug club
the fb there was one and i will say this
there was one person
at a centra a bureau of intel i won't
say which one
one person who actually cared and said
how did you get into this encrypt
encrypted app and i was shocked that
they didn't know but there was one
person who was interested these people
didn't have one weapon in utah at a ben
shapiro show they had knives they had
ice picks they had k-bars they had
shotguns
and no one was aware of it it was this
show that stopped it and one of those
people was arrested despite what the
media tried to cover i realized really
quickly oh we assume that it's james
bond and people in the essentials
it's just like anywhere else it's the
dmv only they have the ability to lock
you up without trial so it was youtube
vloggers who found the body that's
what's important here because the fbi
was too busy of course staging a fake
protest for uh january 6. well and i
think they found her the the car the van
right and then the police were called in
and said hey we found that van and then
very close by they found the body so it
was the vloggers and the police yeah put
my name on that report there yeah and
then the news was like yeah the fbi they
did it yeah and i believe the vlogger
was like oh my god bad news she's dead
but good news we got our first viral
video yeah my gosh
death of someone who seemed awful you're
not you're not making fun of the death
at all making fun of the vloggers
to be here they were busy what were they
busy doing instead of keeping tabs on
laundry the fbi was busy doing this
undercover undercover yes what did i
[Laughter]
um
they didn't survey they didn't uh they
weren't surveilling the house the fbi
didn't search the house until monday
his family claims he went on a nature
hike uh september 14th never returned
look
this is not the first example of the fbi
failing to protect little girls let's be
clear about this here this was only
solved not because of joy reid who has a
platform who could have had put out an
apb effectively not because of the fbi
not because of the cia it was solved
because of people on youtube living the
van life for crying out loud and this
comes on the heels of last just last
week where we had the story of the fbi
right they ignored caleb moroney's
testimony and talking
the sexual abuse that went on for what a
decade with the gymnastics team they
didn't report they didn't report this
for the fbi for 17 months
40 more girls were molested 156 total in
total accused but 40 more girls were
arrested
just sorry molested just from the point
that someone had come forward to the fbi
and said you have to do something about
this and they didn't put the paperwork
in the right stack i mean at the very
least you just pause the doctor's
ability to do his job like okay we're
just gonna have to look into this what
is it
yeah it's like 105 cases so far so that
might be enough i'm sorry i'm still on
nature walk yeah
hey your girlfriend's missing i'm gonna
go uh uh you know nature walk at a
bushel basket of pine cones right i'm
gonna go on the appalachian trail walk
i'll be back in three months find some
non-poison berries like a pie
this is keenan when this is the fbi
they didn't they didn't arrest epstein
twice well what proof did they have
besides enough ah they had warrants they
i think they actually had reason to
arrest we're talking about what 2007 and
2002 occasions like we don't know where
he is just go where there's young girls
he has an island try there
on the sex island perhaps ask bill
clinton hey
go anywhere and ask around for pedophile
island that's a good place to start
when they're like i don't know i was
like i'm not a mind reader come on how
do i how am i supposed to know just
because he's on a registry
the island is named pedophile it's
island there are lots of those
yeah tons of them you have no idea how
many pedophile islands are in the phone
book you know how many times i go to buy
a plane ticket and they're like which
pedophile island or are you referencing
and i say no i specifically said not
pedophile island yeah and there's a good
chance you end up there anyway because
there's so many of them that's another
home alone
you know oh
wait
the fbi's what do you mean pedophile
island and i'm in new york
the fbi on pedophilia oh good he's in
new york and i'm in new york yeah home
alone five where they take the girl and
fly her to pedophile island to give
massages home alone
feel like a comedy
that'll get funny and there are notes of
funny and there are no
traps no no no you the only trap you've
already been caught yeah just at the
beginning of you you are the trap my
colleague call can i have a specific set
of skills yeah i don't know
it involves christmas
i don't care who killed him or if he
killed himself i'm just glad he's dead
this guy epstein
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no no not this
i don't know this guy oh i thought yeah
he's got the worst we don't really have
that no but epstein yeah no um uh no
natural causes yeah in this pinecone
penis
yeah i mean cameras broke guards went
missing that's why he was he was able to
do something that's physically almost
impossible to do
and i want to i want to get your walk i
want to end it with this we're going to
go to mug club here look let me ask you
people out there have you ever had to
deal with law enforcement or let's say
you actually had to deal with the fbi or
cia or actual central intelligence
agencies serious serious question to you
guys out there um because let's keep
saying i keep hitting this thermometer
um
i'm curious because i've had to deal
with that myself you know we've had some
pretty serious threats yeah
the issue here is when you have joy when
you look at every problem as a
uh when your only tool is a hammer right
you look at every problem as a nail and
so their solutions why isn't the fbi
less racist why aren't authorities
insert whatever is here why don't we
have a larger centralized bureau same
thing by the way we can go through any
story that we've had today vox talking
about unemployment right well 41 of
people don't want to take the jobs that
are available why don't we have the
government step in and okay look first
off if you believe that the government
tends to make decisions
more effectively than you that affect
your own life
i think that you are sorely mistaken but
that's an opinion
factually the fbi the cia our
intelligence agencies have dropped the
ball on every single instance where it
was a layup for them in the last
five six years and the solution coming
from the left is put more faith in them
it's just as simple as a solution from
the leftist we need gun control okay so
then what do i do call the cops which
cops the racist ones we tell you not to
trust
hey uh you know what we need a more
effective we need more effective
intelligence uh here which intelligence
agency the one that we don't trust
because you're talking about bill barr
yeah so no don't trust so in other words
it's the same thing you have going on
with joy reid saying of course don't
trust the vaccine because donald trump
is president right now and the very next
day trust
this giant centralized bureaucracy
whichever example that day whether it's
a cdc fda and i don't know which the
science you trust at this point because
the fda just resoundingly said no third
booster for the population at large and
fouchy disagrees with them which the
science do you trust now it's like a
schism of the church
it's like the worm diets for fauci i
don't know which the science you trust
here's my point to you don't trust any
of it certainly don't trust the fbi who
russiagate
james comey hillary clinton emails
right we talk we can talk about their
conviction rates we can talk about
january 6. we can talk about the
governor whitmer plot where they were
actually planning it we can talk about
them being they can't even successfully
send in 14 out of out of
29 agents and stop a coup
and you're supposed to trust your life
to these people and i have no idea if
patito did but here's what i will say to
everyone out there i want to see far
fewer stories of people like petito i
want to see far fewer stories of people
like the girls who were molested by the
by the gymnastics coach and what does it
start with
and this is you know and i'm gonna aim
some aim some fire here on the right
when you have these identitarians who go
have more kids no no it doesn't start
with just having kids your penis is not
the revolution gun okay it starts with
raising kids it starts with being a
father i know people who say oh we're
going to preserve american culture here
you know because we have a bunch of
immigrants and so i have a big family
and all of them are blue haired
feminists you screwed up you made it
worse what you need to start with is
raising your family with the right
values and making them aware that they
need to keep their head in a swivel hey
remember we were kids with the buddy
system let's bring that back holding
hands teaching young women to avoid
scenarios that could put them at risk
not teaching young women hey just be
ready to call the cops so you can be the
next amber alert you know what else
fewer petitos if all women are carrying
and learn how to shoot a firearm guess
what my daughter is going to have a gun
in her hand at the range as soon
as she is old enough to understand the
mechanism of fire why because i want her
to be comfortable with it and i want her
to live a life
autonomously from people who are meant
to keep her safe look
before we get to
there's a reason state government is
more effective than local government and
there's a reason that municipal
government is more effective than state
government and there's a reason that
your community
or white people if you reached out to
people in your community at this point
as opposed to holding yourself up with
your mask there's a reason that people
in your community would be more
effective in knowing what you need on
your block than someone in your state
legislature and then we downsize guess
what there's a reason that people in
your family know what's best for you and
then let's scale it down there's a
reason that you know how to best keep
yourself safe and you have all of these
talking heads out there saying it's
someone else we need the government we
need the fbi all they do
is screw up and the people telling you
to trust the folks in charge of the
screwed upness are the ones who want to
strip you of your autonomous rights
to do it more effectively in the first
place don't trust the fbi arm yourself
get a concealed carry permit don't rely
on a police response time have an exit
plan and a gun on every floor and in
every room
don't rely on me too and someone else to
come forward and champion your cause
have a buddy system and make sure that
when you go out you're you're surrounded
by people who are making sure that your
drinks are safe that you know when
you're getting home that you have a
curfew that someone who can keep track
of you
but you don't see people talking about
this in the media it's look to some
transcendent savior uh to help you yeah
yeah put your faith in the fbi
if you believe that you may be joyride
okay we're going to talk about the kim
jong-un thing okay
mug club uh also when i met john candy
uh youtube thank you i don't give a
rat's ass if you don't like us talking
about these things because joy reid did
it first piss off